after two hours of statements stressing
the need to remember the past support
for the Armenian Genocide resolution was
so one sided that there was no need to
tally the votes and now for the rules
Lucien as a whole who is in favor who is
against thank you very much it has been
adopted with a wide majority thank you
very much but turkish President wretched
high a Bedouin shrugged off the EU's
opinion even before the vote he says
those who hold his country responsible
for Ottoman atrocities tarnished turkeys
history oh boy Billy parlamento subunit
I don't know what the European
Parliament will decide to do today
whatever decision the European
Parliament makes on armenia's genocide
claims it will go in one ear and out the
other because turkey will never accept
this sin it's a crime these turkey the
country which emerged from the Ottoman
Empire was home to millions of Armenians
before World War one in april nineteen
fifteen Ottoman soldiers began rounding
up Armenian men and the rest of the
population was expelled from their
homeland it's estimated up to a million
and a half hour minions perished turkey
acknowledges killings took place but
insists they were part of wartime chaos
on all sides the controversy came to the
fore again after Pope Francis on Sunday
described the Armenia killings as the
first genocide of the 20th century
turkey quickly condemned the remarks but
as the anniversary draws nearer the
genocide debate is likely to remain the
charged issue for turkey's leaders